hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute möchten wir ein sehr
schnelles leckeres und sehr schönes
rezept machen denn wir machen heute
blumen und cupcakes und zwar werde ich
jetzt erst mal einen ganz normalen
muffin teig herstellen
dann nehme ich immer ganz gern meinen
buttermilch macht und weil die einfach
so schön luftig sind und sehr saftig
sind und außerdem sind sie total einfach
deswegen stellen wird erstmal die mafia
und später zeigt euch wie ich meine
leckere buttercreme machen
also ich mache freut die doppelte menge
aber ich zeige euch die mengen für ein
muffin blech genau und später bemale ich
mit samira noch das schöne model
häuschen
also ich habe jetzt hier auch die
doppelte menge stehen
aber ich sage euch die einfache menge
und zwar brauche ich zwei eier 100 gramm
zucker 60 milliliter sonnenblumenöl 300
milliliter buttermilch ich brauche etwas
vanille extrakt eine zitrone und ich
brauche 350 gramm weizenmehl hier einen
teelöffel natron und teelöffel kein
problem bischof ist krank zuerst gehen
wir jetzt die eier in die rührschüssel
machst du das
dann kommt er mit reiner zusammen
es ist ziemlich schwer und es heißt
jetzt erst mal richtig schön schaumig
rühren und gebt da jetzt gleich noch
eine prise salz mit dazu habe ich
vergessen herauszustellen
also sieht jetzt diese eier masse aus
sie habe ich jetzt bei höchster stufe
etwa 34 minuten rühren lassen
jetzt gebe ich die buttermilch mit ryan
ich dich doch beides lassen wir jetzt
kurz bei niedriger stufe einrühren
derzeit kann ich schon mal das öl
das gebe ich es auch mir dazu
ganz laut
jetzt auch gleich noch mal ihre extrakte
zu
dazu ein paar tropfen
die zimmer gleich fertig denn jetzt muss
ich nur noch die zitronenschale abhalten
ich habe das auch als kind immer
probiert da war der kuchen immer
leckerer als der leader war der tag
immer leckere als depot hat genau ich
habe mein kind ist jetzt kannst du die
zitrone so bis zu zerdrücken mit der
hand genau das reicht schon
dann kommt nämlich das sagt leichter
raus und jetzt gebe ich einfach noch den
zitronensaft meter tief
das gab sturm machen okay jetzt über die
schüssel den letzten rest drücke ich dir
noch aus die kerne rein drücken hier
wieder rein
jetzt drücken
und jetzt geben wir backpulver und
natron mit zu mehr da rein und es
berühren wir ganz kurz dann vermischt
sich das schön und bildet einfach keine
klumpen weil es kein natron hat kann
auch gerne einfach eine ganze packung
backpulver benutzen geht auch aber mit
natron gehen sie noch ein bisschen
besser auf und jetzt gebe ich das
komplette mail mit dem backpulver
unternehmen mit zum teig und du drehst
dich bitte beim hochstuhl weg kennt und
das laste 2 niedriger stufe einführen
jetzt habe ich hier schon meine
backformen mit den muffin papierfähnchen
ausgelegt und nehmens portion ära des
schützen ganz normaler großer und gibt
es immer einen löffel da in der muffin
form rein also aus meinem backblech oder
mit meinem backblech und mit meinem 1
portionierer bekomme ich keine zwölf
machen sondern etwas so 15 bis 16
könnt ihr euch müsste einfach
ausprobieren wie groß auf in form ist
und wie groß der aktionäre ist wobei ich
sie immer so bis dreiviertel ungefähr
befüllen
jetzt kommen die muffins in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
und unterhitze für ungefähr 13 bis 15
minuten und danach hast du dann komplett
abkühlen
meine muffins ist abgekühlt die habe ich
jetzt hier einfach auf so einem abkühlen
gitter stehen ohne zweites mein posting
vorbereiten und braucht dafür nur ganz
wenige zutaten die zeige ich euch jetzt
mal ganz kurz
also ich brauche nur drei zutaten im
prinzip dass ich einmal butter
frischkäse und puderzucker und alles in
gleicher menge und bei mir ist so ich
habe jetzt ganz viel davon und mache
eine ganz große menge aber ihr braucht
im prinzip nur 150 gramm weiche butter
150 gramm puderzucker und 150 frischkäse
die butter ist immer warm der frischkäse
ich ein bisschen noch kalt ansonsten
wird die creme einfach viel so flüssig
und zum verfeinern nehme ich jetzt
einfach noch ein bisschen vanille
extrakt und wer will noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft oder schale
ich habe jetzt halt wieder dieses
zitronen extrakt weil es einfach
intensiver schmeckt und ich hab keine
zitronen mehr beheben
das ist einfacher kommt und jetzt gebe
ich zuerst die butter in einer
rührschüssel popstars da drin
dann kommt da gleich der puderzucker mit
rein und ich lass das jetzt so etwa 234
minuten lang cremig rühren dann wird das
ganze auch immer heller erstmal bei
niedriger stufe wie es sich ein bisschen
vermischt hat und wenn ihr seht der
puderzucker ist schon
in der butter mit drin und staub nicht
mehr so dann könnte hochschalten
übrigens brauche ich auch gleich ein
paar lebensmittelfarben und zwar nehme
ich einfach hier diese verpassten
ich habe jetzt für die cupcakes brauche
ich jetzt gleich nur blau aber die gibt
es auch in fünf oder sechs sechs
verschiedenen farben rot schwarz rosa
gelb grün
denn die bisschen höher schalten
so sieht die butter masse jetzt aus also
richtig schön weiß cremig und locker
luftig mancher wird jetzt sagen flüssig
aber das wort finde ich total hässlich
deswegen locker luftig
manchmal geht zwar um kochen einfach
wörter die mag ich nicht flüssig oder
wie heißt es beim risotto schatz wie
heißt es beim risotto erschloss sich
dass ich ganz eklig ist schon richtig
eklige sword das geht gar nicht
jetzt gebe ich noch meinen zitronen
extrakt mit dazu und ihr könnt da jetzt
gerne so wie gesagt zitronenschale
reingeben finde ich ein richtig lecker
und etwas vanille extrakt einfach für
das tolle aroma könnte man natürlich
auch andere aromen nehmen wenn ihr jetzt
zum beispiel die muffins auch nicht mit
zitronensaft und zitronenschale gemacht
habt sondern mit etwas anderem zum
beispiel mehr vanille und ihr macht so
ein vanille muffin oder mal ballack
könnte auch einfach nur vanille benutze
wohl irgendwas anderes an kaffee
das nur etwa eine halbe minute
mit ihrer stufe
und da ich die buttercreme auch schon
fertig das klingt wahrscheinlich
ziemlich komische also butter mit
puderzucker und frischkäse aber das ist
wirklich für mich so mein lieblings
topping auf cupcakes vor allem weil es
durch den frischkäse ziemlich leicht
wird und etwas säuerlich nicht so nicht
so schwer wie einfach nur butter
schmeckt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so
nach butter und teile ich mir jetzt hier
kurz auf denn ich mache ja später noch
ein paar andere muffins oder cupcakes
und möchte die blumen die ich heute
mache zweifarbig machen
jetzt habe ich hier eine ganz kleine
menge und da gebe ich jetzt etwas
brauereien grad man erst mal so zwei
tropfen
die sind halt wirklich hoch konzentriert
also da braucht man wirklich ganz wenig
farbe nur und diese hier jetzt ich habe
die von deco back immer ganz gern weil
die einfach ohne ohne diese
kennzeichnungspflichtigen azo farbstoffe
sind also die sind halt echt
unbedenklich für kinder und deswegen
nehme ich die halt immer super gerne
nehme jetzt nochmal zwei tropfen weil es
habe ich ein schönes hellblau finde ich
auch super schön aber ich will gleich
einen kontrast zu dem weiß haben also
mache ich ein bisschen dunkler und so
kann man einfach selber bestimmen wie
dunkel oder wie hält man die farbe haben
will
die kriegen und die creme die weiße
creme gebe ich jetzt ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank damit ich sie gleich besser
spritzen kann wirklich nur so 1 bis 2
minuten
jetzt ist nämlich noch ziemlich weich
aber ich möchte dass sie ein bisschen
fester wird weil es einfach beim
spritzen einfacher ist gebe ich das
mach' kurz der borat ist super weil dann
kann ich in der zeit danke
germain spritzbeutel vorbereiten also
die blumen die ich heute mache das sind
das toll so die optik von ich hoffe ich
spreche es richtig aus von 14
andreas richtig hier sind wie hyazinthen
hat sehr wie für und deswegen mache ich
die jetzt blau weiß und nehmen dafür
jetzt diesen diese spritztour
also das ist eine mit 14 mm durchmesser
und es sieht fast so aus wie ein stern
schule ist aber so nach innen
geschlossen
also eine stern schüler ist ja so wissel
offen mit den spitzen und die hier ist
eben nach innen verschlossen und die
zwei nämlich später war ja noch andere
als fix machen möchte und jetzt nehme
ich mein spritzbeutel diesmal jetzt ohne
adapter
den adapter nehme ich immer gerne wenn
ich zb spritztouren auch mal wechseln
will und dann geht es besser jetzt
stelle ich es einfach ein schiebt dies
nach vorne ein bisschen zurück und kann
der spitze abschneidet und dann einfach
durchdrücken
jetzt gebe ich das hier gleich in mainz
wurde ständern aber ich freue mich jetzt
ein bissel auf und macht einfach ganz
kurz auf die krähen eine creme sind
jetzt wieder karls jetzt endlich ein
sprit zeuge gefüllt und ich möchte dass
das xoom also einer 2 farben optimal
jetzt stelle ich mir das einmal über
genannt normalerweise mache ich da immer
gerne im spritzbeutel spender aber jetzt
muss ich denn der hand machen denn das
blaue kommt jetzt nur an den rand also
das wird jetzt hier wirklich nur am rand
entlang gestrichen und in der mitte
kommt dann weiß wenn du auch so machen
dass ihr das hier erschlossen
zusammenrückt und hat das nämlich
überall am rand dann öffnen was einfach
wieder
und jetzt muss ich nur gucken dass unten
richtung loch hülle oder richtung
spritzt hülle da einfach die öffnung
frei bleibt ich weiß noch wie das jetzt
wird durch sehen würden
das gedacht zusammengefügt aber
vielleicht sieht man dass praktisch die
türe jetzt nicht verstopft ich mit dem
blau sondern da kommt dann gleich weiß
rein und jetzt fühle ich direkt es weiß
nach das mache ich jetzt aber hier das
geld jetzt einfach für mich
dann sitzt auch einstecken
jetzt einfach das weiß noch rein
jetzt sind spritzt hoch nehmen und
einmal schütteln
jetzt drücke ich hier einmal ganz kurz
den ersten rest rausschaut meistens noch
ein bisschen luft mit drin
und jetzt ausweis kommt jetzt kann ich
beginne also am besten im die euch jetzt
so einen cupcake
ich stelle mir den ich da drauf und
jetzt drücken wir von also wir fangen
außen an und immer so ganz kleine
bewegungen
deswegen ist hier wichtig dass die creme
nicht so weich ist ansonsten verläuft
euch das nämlich ziemlich schnell könnte
jetzt einfach noch für die lücken füllen
wenn ihr wollt ihr könnt auch so lassen
und dann haben wir richtig schöne
cupcakes
man hat jetzt auch statt weiß einfach
eine andere farbe machen können wie rosa
zum beispiel sieht auch hübsch aus
und setzt sich hier einfach noch ein
paar schmetterlinge drauf das muss man
natürlich nicht ich für die capex so
auch schon richtig schön aber ich find
das gibt's nochmal richtigen
frühlingstag oder was denkt stunden vor
ort
doch hübsch
es ist eine plage ja das sind so essbare
opladen die kann schon einfach zusammen
knicke und hier drauf setzen
und so kann man jetzt ziemlich einfach
und relativ schnell richtig schöne
cupcakes zauber maximal einfach einfach
also einfach ja es ist ja jetzt nicht
schwierig also für mich war ziemlich
einfach weil wenn man das richtige
werkzeug dazu hat also zum beispiel
diese spritztour dann es hat die
spritztechnik an sich relativ neu aber
es ist wirklich nicht schwierig also ich
würd man sage für den bug anfänger ist
vielleicht wirklich eine herausforderung
aber für jemand der öfter macht ist
natürlich einfach relativ einfach
ich weiß das ist mein lieblingswort ich
nicht so oft sagt aber es kommt halt
ganz einfach wenn ihr wollt dürfte das
rezept gerne auf meine warlock einfach
auch im blog nachlesen und einfach
nachmachen
jetzt reicht's arbeit gibt eigentlich
dran ich glaube jetzt 80 locker drauf
und zwar könnt ihr das nachlesen auf
sallys - blog.de und ich werde jetzt
noch mal bisschen kühl stellen denn wenn
ich jetzt dran kommen würde würden die
blüten zerstört werden
und jetzt stelle ich sie kühl und kann
sich dann auch richtig schön kühl
servieren und in meinem nächsten video
werdet ihr übrigens sehen wie ich mit
diesem cup cakes auch noch andere capex
spritze also noch andere spritztechnik
und wie man damit sogar so ein richtig
schönes
wie heißt zum blumenstrauß machen kann
aus cupcakes das zeigt ihr euch weiß
rips direkt das nächste video wird oder
1 der nächsten videos auf jeden fall
kommt es demnächst ist bald so einig wie
geht ihr von zwei einfach